It's very important to have co-founders,
mainly because as one
person you can fall sick, you can become
frail, you can run out of energy or
steam, or something can get in
your way as an obstacle and
a co-founder can help you
overcome that obstacle.
So where one is strong two are powerful.
Where two are powerful,
three are ultimate.
It also helps keep things balanced.
It's good to have other opinions
that are not just your own.
I'm not saying sole proprietorship
doesn't work, it just requires
that much more out of you and
sustainability can be a challenge.
So having a co-founder is a very
good way to have somebody
like-minded support the business
in a similar manner to you,
while bringing their own
strengths to the table.
So, for me, the key advantage
to having a co-founder is that
you get to share the load.
You both bring your
strengths to the table and
you're trading your strengths against
the other person's weaknesses.
And that makes for
a very strong cohesive thing.
Affectively you're marrying this
other person for some period of time
because you're both very committed
to what it is you're trying to build